guten abend wir sind live mit zdf heute
live männer kämpfen frauen fliegen das
ist das bild das wir in unseren köpfen
haben im krieg in der ukraine entspricht
das aber null der realität frauen in der
ukraine greifen auch zu den waffen sie
verteidigen ihr land gut 5000 sind
zurzeit direkt an der front darüber
wollen wir heute sprechen wir wollen mit
und über frauen reden die in der ukraine
geblieben sind wir sprechen gleich mit
alena job an die in nikolaev als
polizistin nun auch dem militär angehört
und wir reden mit der filmemacherin
mascha kondakowa sie hat mehrere frauen
über jahre an der front begleitet
sie und ihr könnt sehr gerne fragen
stellen und kommentare posten das geht
am besten in den chats oder eben per
mail wir legen gleich los vorher laura
rosinus über frauen an der front
abschiedsszenen an ukrainischen
bahnhöfen frauen und kinder ergreifen
die flucht in richtung westen in
sicherheit sie müssen sich verabschieden
zurück bleiben die männer verteidigen
ihr land so wird der krieg in der
ukraine häufig dargestellt ein
männlicher krieg
stattdessen die realität frauen
evakuieren zivilisten verarzten soldaten
füllen molotow cocktails ihre aufgaben
sind vielfältig
einige von ihnen sind soldaten mitten im
kriegsgeschehen sowie diese
scharfschützen ihr kampfname hexe sie
ist eine von mehr als 5000 frauen
derzeit an der front vor dem krieg war
die sportschützen jetzt gehörte zur
eliteeinheit der ukraine lange war sie
die einzige frau im team mit ihrer
präzision ist sie allen voraus
kein europäisches militär ist so
weiblich wie das ukrainische vor
kriegsbeginn war mehr als ein fünftel
des militärischen personals frauen damit
liegt der frauenanteil in der
ukrainischen armee deutlich über dem
durchschnitt der nato-länder laut
ukrainischen verteidigungsministerium
dienen als 50.000 frauen
38.000 von ihnen als soldatin die
anderen übernehmen zivile aufgaben
auch polizisten gelten mittlerweile als
teil der streitkräfte sowie online age
of pan sie lebte nikolajew und
dokumentiert dort russische
raketeneinschläge so wie hier in einem
krankenhaus
darauf wurden wir nicht vorbereitet
wir hatten kein entsprechendes training
und unser job hat sich insgesamt
dramatisch verändert die prioritäten
sind jetzt komplett anders
lenas mutter wegen des krieges leben ihr
sohn und ihre tochter momentan bei der
oma für die ukraine wünscht sie sich den
sieg und für sich selbst dass sie bald
wieder mit ihren kindern zusammenlebt
und
jetzt ist sonst live aus micro live
zugeschaltet guten abend franken
abenteuerroman die ukraine als ihr land
ihre heimat angegriffen wurde wann haben
sie entschieden in ihrer heimat zu
bleiben
ich habe nicht einmal die gedanken
gehabt anders zu handeln
vom anfang an
es sei dem 24 februar ich und mein ihr
mann haben beschlossen wir bleiben troy
unserem alter
sie sind nur 30 kilometer entfernt von
der frontlinie also fast mitten drin in
ried ist gegen die roma aber dass er via
die kinderschützen
absolut ich stelle meine frage nochmal
sie sind aktuell nur 30 kilometer
entfernt von der frontlinie sie sind
also quasi mittendrin im krieg wie ist
ihr leben im moment wie hat es sich
verändert
das leben hat sich radikal verändert
es ist ihnen sicherlich bekannt
es seit dem kriegsbeginn
hat es lediglich 22 tage gegeben an
denen bekommt nicht beschossen wurde die
stadt wird nachts beschlossen tagsüber
beschossen mit raketen
mit artillerie
und das ist unser leben so müssen wir
leben und arbeiten seit dem 24 februar
und wir sehen hier bilder aus den
letzten tagen aus nikolaev ihr job es
jetzt dass sie dafür zuständig sind die
zerstörung durch die russische armee zu
dokumentieren warum ist das so wichtig
wir als polizisten als die
polizeiverwaltung
müssen zu den ohren raus fahren wir
müssen fotos machen videoaufnahmen wir
müssen hilfe leisten wenn jemand zu
schaden gekommen ist
anschließend kommen ermittler
die die beweise erfassen
damit diese beweise später
als beweismaterial verwendet werden
können
sie haben uns erzählt sie sind dann auch
immer die ersten die am tatort ankommen
oder an den anschlagsorten und muss
vielleicht so zu nennen
das ist doch dann sicherlich auch oft
eine gefährliche situation
natürliche ss absoluter eine gefährliche
situation
hier der polizist
geht gefahr ein aber wir haben ein
geleistete und es ist uns bewusst wenn
wir diese arbeit nicht leisten bei wird
dieser arbeit dann stattdessen leisten
das müssen wir machen vor uns vor die
zivilbevölkerung vor unsere kinder und
für unsere zukunft wenn wir angst haben
dann werden wir nicht in der lage sein
unsere arbeit nachzugehen
ich möchte nicht sagen dass wir keine
angst haben hier der hat angst aber wir
haben uns angepasste wir haben unser an
dieser arbeit unter diesen bedingungen
angepasst
dazu schreibt sie neu auf youtube dass
sie sehr mutige frauen sind sie haben
aber auch sie sind auch mutter sie haben
zwei kinder die leben zurzeit bei der
oma wie oft können sie sich sehen wie
ist das für die kinder wenn sie so lange
voneinander getrennt sein müssen
wir sehen uns nur wenn es möglich ist
manchmal ist es einmal im monat manchmal
einmal in zehn tagen ich ja nach der
situation in der stadt und je nachdem
wie notwendig ist dass wir vor ort sind
wenn wir zu besuch sind dann
maximal vor 1 tag oder vor zwei tage
mein älterer sohn ist 14 jahre alt er
versteht die situation dass es notwendig
ist das kleinere kind die tochter
dreieinhalb jahre alt rossi ist es
schwer aber
nach vier monaten hat sie sich auch
daran gewöhnt als er weiß wir müssen zur
arbeit
als sie weiß dass wir abwesend sind ich
weiß nicht ob das worte gewöhnt ist
passend ist
natürlich machen wir uns alle sorgen
die kinder möchten zu uns für mich und
für meinen ehemann ist es auch nicht
einfach wir möchten bei den kinder seien
aber wir verstehen dass es derzeit nicht
anders geht wenn die situation sich
einmal verbessert hat dann werden wir
zusammen sein eine unglaubliche
herausforderung für alle beteiligten und
damit haben sie freundlicherweise auch
schon die frage von miss sunshine auf
youtube erklärt wir erklären frauen das
ihren kindern dass sie kämpfen mich
würde interessieren wie ist das in ihrem
umfeld sind wie frauen im land geblieben
in ihrem bekanntenkreis in ihrem
freundeskreis oder sind die meisten
gegangen
[Musik]
alle kolleginnen von mir die mit mir
zusammen dienen
dass fast alle sind in der stadt
geblieben sie sind nicht ausgereist
es gibt frauen die gezwungen waren das
land zu verlassen eine kollegin von mir
ist mit ihren beiden kindern in
deutschland
sie musste das land verlassen
sie wurde dazu gezwungen durch die
umstände aber nicht gleich in den ersten
tagen sondern erst ein monat später
ansonsten die frauen dienen
die kinder sind meistens mit den
großeltern im ausland
es gibt eine frage auf youtube was sagen
diese kämpferischen frauen zu ihren
geflüchteten ukrainerinnen
ich denke der am user spricht die
solidarität untereinander an
wir unterstützen jede
frau kämpft an ihre front jede frau muss
das machen wozu sie in der lage ist und
die frauen die ins ausland gefahren sind
mit ihren kindern ist sie helfen auch
als hier helfen unserer nation aufrecht
zu erhalten aber sie unterstützen
moralisch mit ihren telefonaten wir
spüren diese unterstützung und
wir verurteilen sie möchte auf seiten
der frauen die geblieben sind gibt es
keine verurteilung
wir sind alle mütter jeder hatte
andere umstände
ich würde sie gerne noch mal zur
situation in nikolaev fragen wir hören
dass es razzien gibt auf der suche nach
russischen kollabiert
kollaborateuren wie finden sie diese
personen was können sie uns dazu sagen
die wichtigste funktion der
streifenpolizist
die kontrolle des straßenverkehrs unter
unsere polizei verwaltung
wird auch bei den
straßensperren eingesetzte alle
verkehrsmittel
die die stadt verlassen oder in die
staaten wollen weiter überprüft die
fahrer werden überprüft die papiere die
handys sonstige gegenstände
die
grund
geben vor den verdacht dass er jemand
ein kollaborateur ist
ich würde sie gerne noch mal fragen was
ist ihr ziel ihre motivation wofür
kämpfen sehe also gibt es auch für sie
in den letzten wochen hat es da man
moment gegeben wo sie auch darüber
nachgedacht haben das land zu verlassen
ich möchte ihnen sagen nein
gleich von anfang an als ich die ersten
explosionen in der stadt gehört habe bis
heute
ich habe niemals die gedanken gehabt ich
solche ausreisen ich meine familie mein
ihr mann wir werden immer hier bleiben
und wir werden alles tun was uns möglich
ist und sogar mehr das machen wir für
unsere kinder wir möchten dass unsere
kinder unserer generation in einem
freien land lebte
in demokratie dass sie möglichkeit haben
sich frei zu äußern und das ist das
wofür wofür wir kämpfen wir kämpfen vor
den sieg und für das leben in einem
demokratischen land und dazu möchte ich
ihnen noch 2 kommentare vorlesen von
bobo fox
angelo lena ich habe großen respekt für
ihre selbstlose und harter arbeit ich
hoffe dass der krieg gegen irland
schnellstmöglich auf wird und sich
putins terror bald verzieht und auch von
torino vorjahr sah man kann nur froh
sein dass es solche frauen und männer
gibt die ihr land verteidigen meinen
höchsten respekt wirtschaft beim
gedanken ihn sehr dass sie uns ihre
situation geschildert haben und wünschen
ihnen und ihrer familie alles gute
danke ihnen auch es aber sehr angenehm
für mich das zu hören das freut uns sehr
danke schön
ja welchen einfluss haben ukrainische
frauen auf ihre armee und somit eben
auch auf den krieg was ändert dass
generell an rollenbildern was macht das
mit einer gesellschaft die filmemacherin
maria kondakowa hat versucht darauf
antworten zu finden herausgekommen ist
ein sehr berührender film awards den
kann man sich aktuell in der arte
mediathek anschauen und wir haben jetzt
einen kurzen auszug
eine wehrhafte frau mit schwert und
schild die bereit ist ihr land zu
verteidigen
die mutter heimat statue in kiew dass
frauen sich zum dienst an der waffe
melden war lange illusion sagt mascha
kondakowa sie ist regisseurin des
dokumentarfilms in wars der innere krieg
ich war im krieg und vorher war ich
total unpolitisch und das einzige was
ich mit meinem film ausdrücken wollte
ist was passiert im inneren in der seele
im geist wenn der tod einen täglich
umgeht und wie überwindung diese frauen
ihre ängste ihre müdigkeit um
weiterzumachen
für ihren film begleitete sie von 2014
bis 2016 3 soldatinnen im donbass lehrer
eine ehemalige journalistin
ihrer einem ihnen versehrte sanitäterin
und elena an der front norwich genannt
allen widerständen zum trotz kämpfen
ihre protagonistinnen an vorderster
front sind den gleichen gefahren
ausgesetzt wie ihre männlichen kameraden
kondakowa geboren 1989 in kiew störte
sich an dem bild des nach russlands
einmarsch in den bars medial vom krieg
gezeichnet wurde kämpfen ist männersache
frauen haben hier nichts zu suchen
mit ihrem film wollte die regisseurin
herausfinden was die frauen antreibt
täglich ihr leben aufs spiel zu setzen
herausgekommen ist eine beeindruckende
dokumentation über geschlechterrollen
und emanzipation im angesicht der
schrecken des krieges und
nicht wundern dass der eiffelturm jetzt
im hintergrund ist mascha kondakowa lebt
zurzeit in paris und da treffen wir sie
heute abend an guten abend
guten tag frau
kanagawa sie haben mal gesagt putin hat
nicht mit diesen frauen gerechnet wie
meinen sie das
ich wollte damit sagen
dass wir diese verdeckte kraft haben
ich glaube putin
was er versteht dass es nur die sprache
der stärke
aber wir haben auch die sprache der
hoffnung
weil wir solche frauen haben ich bedanke
mich bei all jener die wir soeben in der
sendung gehabt haben sie hat aber sicher
zelte oder ihrer geschichte
eine frau an der front in so einem
patriarchalen land wie die ukraine und
dazu noch mit zwei kindern
die nicht in der nähe sind an einem
sicheren ort ich glaube
die frauen das ist die hoffnung
sie haben nun mit mehreren frauen
gesprochen die kämpfen was treibt diese
frauen an sich der armee
anzuschließen wofür kämpfen die
sowas hier kämpfen
so eine situation
aggression seitens russland es am 24
februar hat russland die ukraine
überfallen ehrlich gesagt morgen reise
ich nach cava warum
als dieser angriffe stattgefunden hatte
für mich war es eine akute frage mein
wunsch war alles liegen zu lassen und
nach hause zu fahren ich wollte
journalisten unterstützen unter anderem
auch deutsche journalisten
angesichts der
propaganda und die ich wollte hinter der
kamera stehen und mein land auf diese
weise unterstützen warum weil man es
nicht anders kann ich
jahrelang habe ich mit diesen mutigen
frauen gearbeitet
holender lehrer ihrer maria war auch
dabei
jede frau
weshalb heißt der film so genau
weil ich jede frau einen ihren konflikt
hatte oder einen inneren rufe
kriege dass es keine eindeutige frau
wann
eine frau hatte ihre kinder der oma
überlassen eine andere frau hat ein
teile ihres setzte wählen lebens
weggeworfen jede frau hat eine eigene
antwort valeria bokowas journalisten
während der revolution der würde im jahr
2014 ist sie war die ganze zeit auf der
meydan als sie war beim widerstand aber
in der nach der als 100 bürger
mitten in kiew getötet wurden drei tage
lang hat sie nicht geschlafen ihre
freunde als sie hat sich zu einem
phantom
umgewandelte ihre freunde haben zu ihr
gesagt du musst nach hause gehen muss
schlafen du kannst es nicht mehr und
dann kommst du wieder zurück und er wir
machen weiter und wir verteidigen
weiterhin unsere stadt vor den russen es
waren die zeiten von janukowitsch und
sie hat verschlafen dann augenblicke
deshalb hat es denn widerstandes hat sie
verschlafen
sie wollte als journalistin in den krieg
ziehen aber später als sie gehört hat
dass nicht genug männer an der front
sind das war im jahr 2014
2015 hat sie beschlossen mit der waffe
zu kämpfen sie sagte verweist die frage
es ging nicht um
das gewissen es ging darum sie hat das
gefühl gehabt etwas nicht abgeschlossen
zu haben
sie hatte das gefühl der schuld gehabt
die verantwortung
warum wir wurden so erzogen
so sind wir die ukrainerin bei uns sagt
man wille oder tot
und ich glaube
dass es die antwort
aus meiner sicht das wäre die antwort
auf ihre frage morgen reisen aktiv dass
es mein ticket ihre kollegen haben mir
geholfen denn tigerte auszudrucken danke
ihnen
für ihr interesse
das so dass ihr diese sendung heute
machen vielen dank ja so sind wir beim
zdf wird drucken bei bedarf auch gerne
was aus überhaupt kein problem wenn wir
gerade bei den drei frauen sind die in
ihrem film aufgetreten sind mich würde
interessieren was ist aus ihrer geworden
was es aus lehrer und elena geworden
sind die wieder an die front gegangen
valeria burlakow war
als sie war damals die hauptdarstellerin
als sie hatte die liebe ihres lebens
gefunden und wieder verloren durch eine
mine
sie hat ein kind ihr sohn ist 23 jahre
alt ihre mutter
als sie kam nach deutschland
noch vor dem 24
februar
natürlich ihre erste wunsch war
wieder an die front zur reise nach kiew
damals weiß heiße in kiew aber ihr sohn
hat zu ihr gesagt mama ich werde das
ganze spielzeug hier geben bleibt wird
er hier und wir konnten nichts erwidern
es ist ihr bewusst dass ihre rolle jetzt
sieben jahre lang war sie bei den
streitkräften
sechs jahre lang war sie an der front
sie war an den heißesten stellen
sie war an den kämpfen
beteiligt
jetzt arbeitet sie als freiwillige ist
die hilfe mit fahrzeugen ist hier
kümmert sich darum dass
in deutschland gebrauchte fahrzeuge
gekauft werden können unter an die
fronte
überführt werden können
verkehrsmittel es sind sehr wichtig wenn
es verwunderte gibt und es gibt keine
fahrzeuge oder
kein drei stoffe ist eher schwierig
vielleicht ist es so weil sie ihre liebe
so tragisch verloren hatte wenn
ihr ein paar minuten früher an das
krankenhaus eingeliefert werden hätte
können wäre er am leben geblieben
die andere person die hexe und anna
metzger sie ist nach wie vor im krieg
ist in mallorca im gebiet donezk
ihr mann den sie während des films
geheiratet hatte das sind sehr zeitliche
augenblicke diese im film werden können
vor zwei monaten
war er im krankenhaus
wegen einer konfusion
ihrer tochter sie ist etwas über 20 es
auch bei den streitkräften aber in einer
anderen abteilung
hexe ist die
beute nannte aber ihre tochter ist
woanders es ja hat mir gesagt einmal
konnte sie mehrere tage lang mit der
tochter nicht sprechen sie hat sich
viele sorgen gemacht und ihr sohn ist in
haag ihrer die frau
die ebenfalls ein sehr tragisches
schicksal gehabt hat das ist ein sehr
hoher preis denn alle frauen bezahlt
haben
bei uns gibt es
keine zwangsweise
mobilmachung bei den ukrainischen
streitkräften und trotzdem so viele
frauen
50.000 frauen sind bei den streitkräften
38.000 davon mit der waffe
ihrer wo der verwunderte
an eine mine in
einem einsatz aber sie hat es überlebte
es sie wissen irgendwelche situation sie
jetzt erst ist sie ist lehrerin und
endlich mal
se mit ihren
eltern zusammen sie hat ein sehr
schwieriges verhältnis zu den eltern
gehabt
diese minenunfall sie arbeitete sie
studiert weiterhin und so haben diese
drei frauen unterschiedliche schicksale
geht dass das leben auf völlig
unterschiedliche art und weise weiter
ich hatte noch eine andere frage es gibt
berichte über furchtbare
kriegsverbrechen am vergewaltigungen
eben insbesondere auch an frauen war das
auch thema bei dem gespräch die sie
geführt haben
ja natürlich aber
ich muss ihnen sagen
valeria bulacan war sagt es mir
das was ich gespürt habe
auch viel liebe findet statt im krieg
aber
das was die russischen soldaten in der
ukraine machen ich hoffe sehr dass das
internationale
gericht
verfahren ober diese kriegsverbrechen
führen kann das ist natürlich eine
andere seite des krieges und das ist
eine andere waffe dass es eine mentale
waffe es ist schwierig schwanger zu
werden von einem feind
ich habe nicht gehörte
es seitdem ich im osten im gebiet donezk
lohans gefahr
keine frau hat zu mir gesagt
keine einzige frau hat mehr
oberverwaltungsrichter
es soldaten gehörte vor kurzem habe ich
einen post gelesen
es ging um das gesetzte nachdem
ukrainische frauen
auch krank bekommen können bei den
ukrainischen streitkräfte bis zum jahr
2016 hat es
keine
gegeben
wenn sie meter einem
minenwerfer gearbeitet haben wurden sie
tatsächlich als kirchen rekrutierte und
die posten die ränge wurden weiter
dieses verfahren ist noch nicht
abgeschlossen
die soldaten form wird verändert vor
kurzem
hat es einen vorfall gegeben
ein mann
hatte eine frau mit dem fahrzeug
mitgenommen es kam zu
handgreiflichkeiten
als sie ist ohnmächtig geworden ich weiß
nicht ob es zur vergewaltigung gekommen
ist oder nicht ein strafverfahren wurde
eingeleitet und der robert ermittelte
aber das ist der einzige absolut der
einzige fall von dem ich es seit dem
jahr 2014 weiß und wenn so was
vorkommt dann muss man darüber sprechen
und natürlich männer und frauen wir sind
alle unterschiedliche
tatsächlich aber wir haben die gleichen
rechte
tatsächlich ging es auch eher um
kriegsverbrechen durch die russische
armee aber sie haben eben angesprochen
momentan gibt es noch relativ wenige
ranghoher soldaten in der ukrainischen
armee aber das ist ja auch ein prozess
trotzdem vielleicht kommen wir auf eine
unserer eingangs fragen zurück auf
welche art und weise beeinflussen frauen
die ukrainische armee und damit eben
auch den krieg
ich glaube
bei den streitkräften hat man damit gar
nicht gerechnet dass so viele frauen
kommen werden um ihre familien um ihr
land zu verteidigen
dass er sein prozess natürlich bedarf es
zeit ich kann ihnen sagen
dank der aktivistinnen dann der
feministinnen in der ukraine
das wort für minis muss ist nicht so
sehr in im gebrauch die frauen zeigen
lediglich mit ihrer arbeit ihre rolle
als sie bekommen diese rolle durch ihre
kompetenzen ich hoffe sehr
natürlich haben wir eine sprecherin dass
es auch eine frau das ist die frage der
zeit
es gibt eine veränderungen statt die
ukraine
wir entwickeln uns permanent wir möchten
uns weiterentwickeln nach der musik
werden wir das land wieder aufbauen
im namen aller ukrainer und
ukrainerinnen
möchte ich mich bei ihnen lieber
zuschauer bedanken dafür dass sie ihre
herzen geöffnet haben dafür dass sie
ukrainischen frauen und ihren kindern
helfen dafür dass sie ihnen ermöglicht
haben am leben zu bleiben
die kinder werden zusammen mit den
deutschen kindern die schulen besuchen
vielleicht sind sie im urlaub zusammen
es findet ein austausch statt ukraine
sind sehr arbeitsam und wenn wir wieder
das land aufbauen faden werden wir eine
ganz andere grundlage haben
was wir bei ihnen was wir bei unserer
umsetzen können was wir bei ihnen in
deutschland gesehen haben in frankreich
in anderen europäischen ländern vielen
dank an sie kinder dass es unsere
zukunft danke ihnen
haben sie die möglichkeit dazu leben als
sich zu entwickeln zu lernen
ich komme auf ihre frage zurück die
veränderungen finden bereits statt
absolut ich möchte ihnen noch einige
kommentare zum schluss vorlesen norbert
schreibt diese frauen haben mehr mut als
die ganze russische imperialistischer
armee zusammen prinzessin diana von
baden schreibt auf youtube dort niemand
mehr das recht vom schwachen geschlecht
zu reden beschreibt tolle frauen die
ukraine muss gewinnen
achso und einen haben wir noch von usd
schreibt nämlich auch extra dazu dass er
männlich ist er schreibt ich wünschte
frauen würden die welt regieren dann
wäre die welt friedlicher eine letzte
frage noch an sie wie werden ukrainische
soldatin rollenbilder in ihrem land
verändern und was wird das aus der
ganzen gesellschaft machen
die veränderungen finden bereits statt
es selbst die frauen die nicht direkt an
der front center oder die männer als sie
helfen alle die ukraine heute das ist
eine große familie
wir sind alle zusammen
innerhalb von wenigen minuten kann alles
gelöst werden es ist ganz einfache
verbindung herzustellen
selbst wenn jemand fror bekannt berühmt
war weil wir diesen geist haben wir sind
nicht zu überwinden frau kondakowa
vielen dank dass sie heute abend zeit
für uns hatten ich wünsche ihnen alles
gute und machen sie's gut 100
vielen dank für ihre unterstützung
bleiben sie weiterhin mit der ukraine
vielen dank danke ihnen
ja und auch innen und euch vielen dank
für eure meinungen und für eure fragen
wir haben versucht alles mögliche
einzubauen wir sehen uns hoffentlich
bald wieder biss dann tschüss